a very um distressing image
has
been given to sky news from a lifeboat
captain showing
what we understand to be the remains of
that boat it is um
a the remains of a dinghy a flimsy
thingy out at sea we know that a lot of
these boats are not seaworthy um and it
is
obviously incredibly uncomfortable to
see a day since 27 people lost their
lives and it's a sad day here in france
it's a sad day in britain and sad of
course for the families of those 27
people that were trying to make it over
to
the uk and of course there's going to be
a refocusing too on the politics of all
this a cooperation between the british
and the french yesterday in a call
between emmanuel macron and
boris johnson they said that they
urgently need to step up efforts said
that
there needs to be cooperation from the
whole of europe beyond just france and
britain and i think that's a message
that we'll hear echoed again and again
because we understand now too that the
boat
came from germany which i think shows
that you know the route to this problem
isn't here in calais it is further
afield and that is what
british and french authorities are
focusing on